Comin' over in my direction
So thankful for that, it's such a blessin', yeah
Turn every situation into heaven, yeah
Oh-oh, you are
My sunrise on the darkest day
Got me feelin' some kind of way
Make me wanna savor every moment slowly, slowly
You fit me tailor-made, love how you put it on
Got the only key, know how to turn it on, The way you nibble on my ear, the only words I wanna hear
Baby, take it slow so we can last long
Oh, you, you are the magnet and I'm the metal
I keep getting closer and building up the plan
Just thinking about it raises my heartbeat
Oh, yeah I, I'm already liking you more than usual
All my senses are asking for more
This needs to be taken with no hurry
Slowly
I want to smell your neck slowly
Let me whisper things in your ear
So that you'll remember if you're not with me
Slowly
I want to undress you with my kisses, slowly
I sign the walls of your labyrinth
And make your whole body a manuscript
(Hop on, hop on, hop on!
Hop on, hop on!)
I want to see your hair dance
I want to be your rhythm
And you show my mouth
Your favorite places
(Favorite, favorite, baby)
Let me surpass your danger zones
To make you scream
And you forget your last name
If I ask you for a kiss, come, give it to me
I know that you're thinking about it
I've been trying for a while
Baby, this is giving and giving it
You know that your heart with mine makes you go bang-bang
You know that she is looking for my bang-bang
Come, taste from my mouth to see what it tastes like
I want to, I want to, I want to see how much love you can take in
I am not in a hurry, I want to take the trip
Let's start slow, then wild
Step by step, smooth and gentle
We're sticking together, little by little
When you kiss me with such skill
I see that you're malice with tenderness
Step by step, smooth and gentle
We start sticking, little by little
And such beauty is a puzzle
But to solve it here I have the piece, Listen!
Slowly
I want to smell your neck slowly
Let me whisper things in your ear
So that you remember if you're not with me
Slowly
I want to undress you with my kisses, slowly
I sign the walls of your labyrinth
And make your whole body a manuscript
(Hop on, hop on, hop on!
Hop on, hop on!)
I want to see your hair dance
I want to be your rhythm
And you show my mouth
Your favorite places
(Favorite, favorite, baby)
Let me surpass your danger zones
To make you scream
And you forget your last name
Slowly
This is how we do it down in Puerto Rico
I just wanna hear you screaming, “Oh my god!”
I can move forever when it is with you, Dance!
Step by step, smooth and gentle
We're sticking together, little by little
You show my mouth
Your favorite places
(Favorite, favorite, baby)
Step by step, smooth and gentle
We're sticking together, little by little
Until we provoke screams (Fonsi)
And you forget your last name (D.Y.)
Slowly